su corazón bombea sangre oxigenada por
todo el cuerpo los impulsos eléctricos
rítmicos dentro de su corazón hacen que
sus paredes musculares se contraigan
asegurando que su corazón lata a un
ritmo constante si ocurren problemas con
el sistema eléctrico de su corazón puede
desarrollar latidos del corazón
anormales y potencialmente mortales
denominados arritmia es posible que su
médico desee que se le inserte un
desfibrilador cardioversor implantable o
cd por sus siglas en inglés para
restaurar el ritmo normal del corazón y
evitar una muerte súbita cardíaca
durante el procedimiento
su médico deslizará un cable pequeño a
través de una vena hasta que llegue a su
ventrículo derecho
los cables controlan el ritmo cardíaco
de forma continua después de verificar
que el cable esté en el lugar correcto y
funcione apropiadamente su médico unirá
el cable al generador y cede luego su
médico insertará el dispositivo y cede
por debajo de la piel de su pecho debajo
de la clavícula el aparato y cede a
baterías controla constantemente los
latidos de su corazón
de una computadora si se produce una
arritmia mortal el aparato y cede envía
una descarga eléctrica a su corazón
reajustando los latidos de su corazón el
aparato y cede también puede ser
programado para marcarle el ritmo al
corazón y restaurar su ritmo natural